when drivers speed along germany's
autobahns the scenery tends to be just a
blur but here's a real head turner a
roadside chapel that's a prettier place
to pray while on the road
highways and rest stops are inhospitable
places who would want to linger
here the journey is not the reward it's
about getting from a to b as quickly as
possible
then slap bang in the middle of this
traffic hell
heavenly peace
a space for a dialogue with your inner
self
the highway chapel in zigaland in
western germany
this oasis has been nominated for the
dam prize for architecture in germany
i have to admit we were a bit aghast it
was a pretty hardcore place i thought
how can you build something there that
conveys emotionality hope and faith it
should spirit you far away and remain
very much in the here and now
is one half of schneider and schumacher
an architecture firm based in frankfurt
the company made its name with the
temporary viewing structure that stood
first on
plots in berlin and then by the city's
central station
and with a spectacular extension of the
stadled museum in frankfurt and the
developments of that city's vesthofen
and now with this highway chapel which
was a rare opportunity
it's great being able to build a church
it's not common these days there are
very few churches being built and of
course for architects churches have
always been the most wonderful buildings
imaginable because they're not so
functional
the highway sign for a church was the
initial inspiration
a visual symbol that's instantly
recognizable
from the front the highway chapel looks
like a piece of origami with the light
falling through two pointed ears
abstraction is always a possible method
we needed something as visually strong
as the nearby pylon the highway sign for
a church and the church symbol in
general was a promising cipher
outside austere beauty
and inside
we can get a good idea of that from the
model under the roof a vaulted ceiling
made of humble chipboard
it creates a sacred atmosphere akin to a
gothic cathedral
and this is an essential criterion for
spirituality is that you don't recognize
where the light's coming from the inner
shell and the outer shell are not
identical there's something in between
whatever that is the holy spirit our
dear lord something else that was our
light motif from the outset
motorway churches are a predominantly
german phenomenon
the first gas station for the soul was
built 50 years ago
now there are total of 40 across germany
here you can recover from the stresses
and strains of autobahn driving
these churches are not affiliated with
any one denomination
and are architecturally pretty way out
so
who really uses them
nowadays people come from all around the
world in the summer a lot of people came
on foot or by bike and they stopped off
here it was very important to us that
this was an interfaith church open to
everyone
and literally open 24 7.
people frequently come here in the
middle of the night or to friday prayers
sometimes they pen moving life stories
in the visitors book about separations
they've been through or accidents
they've recovered from
the kings of the road can take away free
copies of the trucker's bible
the church is popular with the public
it's absolutely beautiful something
really special
the church was funded by donations and
in contrast to many other churches these
days people do come here
it's up to them what they see in it
both my partner and i believe in
buildings that can't be easily
categorized
this is a wonderful place to take some
time out
before rejoining the fray
you